salut bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
des histoires à la pierre Bellemare
c'est un peu comme des thread mais c'est
des old trade c'est même plus des trade
après ça devient des traits tellement
remontes dans le temps aujourd'hui on va
parler d'une histoire d'escroquerie qui
a rapport avec les œuvres d'art alors il
y en a eu plein des escroqués avec les
œuvres d'art des choses qui sont plus ou
moins surprenantes comme ce peintre
hollandais qui à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale au Pays-Bas avait été
condamné à la peine de mort pour avoir
vendu des tableaux des œuvres nationales
le trésor des Pays-Bas à l'Allemagne
nazie sauf qu'il avait dit non en fait
je leur faisais des faux et on leur dit
non ils étaient vrais il a fait non
c'est défauts il avait été obligé de de
repeindre des faux on dirait que dans le
tribunal pour montrer qu'il était
capable de peindre des faux tellement
faux qu'ils avaient l'air vraie bref il
y a plein d'histoires comme ça
incroyable j'en ai sélectionné une qui
m'a bien marqué pour vous c'est dans les
années 50 entre monsieur Smith et
Monsieur Durand monsieur Smith et
Monsieur durant n'existent pas les noms
ont été changés et on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui connaître le vrai nom de ces
personnes là
dans la vie c'est d'essayer de
constituer de la plus grande collection
privée de grands tableaux de maître il a
quand même un petit but altruiste
derrière puisque a priori voudrait tous
les gays à sa mort à un musée donc c'est
plutôt chouette il accumule pour son
plaisir personnel de son vivant et après
il est gratuit mais monsieur Smith notre
milliardaire américain a une autre
particularité c'est qu'il est
extrêmement radin très proche de ses
sous mais en plus il est il est à
l'heure il est belliqueux il critique
tout par exemple tous les hôtels dans
lesquels il descend quand il y a un
Paris le redoute parce que on sait qu'il
va jamais être satisfait qui va se
plaindre de tout qui laisse jamais un
pourboire par exemple au porteur de
bagages au taxi à ceux qui ouvrent les
portes etc bon c'est pas le gars le plus
sympa à fréquenter je reviens sur lui
dans quelques secondes il y a un
deuxième protagoniste dans cette
histoire c'est Monsieur Durand monsieur
Durand c'est un marchand d'oeuvre d'art
à Paris il est très connu il est très
apprécié très compétent dans son métier
et monsieur Smith c'est l'un clients et
pour dire la vérité monsieur durant
n'apprécie pas beaucoup monsieur Smith
parce qu'il est aussi désagréable avec
lui qu'avec les autres mais en plus de
ça il cherche toujours à négocier les
prix quand il obtient pas le prix que
lui il veut ben il le fait ressentir il
est pas très aimable et il essaie
toujours quand même de renégocier
derrière c'est limite du harcèlement
donc monsieur durant qu'on compose avec
ça parce que ça reste l'un de ces bons
clients mais c'est très difficile pour
lui de travailler avec monsieur Smith on
va pas se concentrer sur toute
l'histoire de leur relation vous avez
compris grosso modo la teneur on va
parler d'un jour particulier au monsieur
Smith de acheter une grande collection
de tableaux à Monsieur Durand et il se
rend du coup au centre d'exposition au
centre de vente de Monsieur Durand
monsieur semi ça arrive il accueilli par
Monsieur Durand et traverse l'immense
galerie c'est magnifique il y a beaucoup
d'oeuvres qui sont exposées et ils
arrivent dans un bureau qui est jusqu'à
chez derrière une porte où là c'est pas
du tout la même ambiance que dans la
galerie si la galerie est propre bien
rangée qu'elle met bien en valeur en
fait les oeuvres le bureau qui est assez
grand somme toute et jonché
littéralement de tableaux qui doivent
être vendus qui attendent pour être
exposés il y en a un petit peu partout
il y en a sur les murs il y en a
directement posé sur le sol et au milieu
de tout ça il y a un bureau où monsieur
Smith s'assoit il a l'habitude c'est là
qui vient d'habitude acheter les
tableaux après de longues négociations
d'ailleurs la longue série de tableaux
contemporains qui va acheter il y a eu
encore une fois beaucoup de palabre
jusqu'à obtenir le prix de vente
monsieur durant s'installe de l'autre
côté de du bureau et ils vont procéder à
l'achat pour une fois monsieur Smith ne
revient pas une énième fois sur le prix
de vente de la collection alors si pose
que le prix qu'il avait négocié du
convenait du coup et au moment où il va
faire le chèque directement à Monsieur
Durand monsieur Smith aperçoit parmi
tous les tableaux qui sont un petit peu
posés à la va-vite sur le côté droit du
bureau un tableau spécifique qui attire
son attention
il est il est là il est abandonné avec
presque derrière les autres tableaux il
y a juste un petit bout qui dépasse il
est pas du tout mis en valeur il
semblerait que ce soit un nutrilo alors
on dit aussi un nutrio je sais pas trop
comment ça se prononce ça représente la
place du terme donc c'est un magnifique
tableau le trio pour pour vous dire sans
rentrer dans les détails ça a été le
peintre en France qui a été le plus
plagié et sur lequel il y a eu le plus
de faux à une certaine époque et là a
priori ce serait un faux en tout cas
c'est ce que dit monsieur Durand quand
monsieur Smith lui demande s'il peut
examiner le tableau monsieur durant lui
dit oui si vous voulez regarder il est
très très bien fait mais je vous le dis
c'est un faux c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
relégué un petit peu comme ça aux
oubliettes mais monsieur Smith est quand
même assez intrigué et le prend pour le
regarder vraiment dans le détail
monsieur Smith ne fait pas que acheter
des tableaux évidemment ici connaît
réellement et on l'observant vraiment
minutieusement pour lui c'est sûr c'est
un vrai c'est un vrai Utrillo et si
c'est un vrai Utrillo c'est d'autant
plus un gros coup parce que ce serait un
des tableaux de cette période blanche
c'est sa meilleure période à ce peintre
là donc ça veut dire que si ce tableau
là que Monsieur durant croix est un faux
est un vrai alors il y en a
littéralement pour une petite fortune
convaincue de ça monsieur Smith fait une
proposition immédiate à Monsieur Durand
il dit voilà je vous en propose 500000
francs alors ça veut pas dire
grand-chose aujourd'hui 500 000 francs
dites-vous que si le tableau est un vrai
500 000 francs c'est 5% de sa valeur si
c'est un vrai mais si c'est un faux bon
c'est déjà assez bien payé j'ai fait la
conversion 500 000 francs de 1950 ça
vaudrait à peu près 15000 euros
aujourd'hui sauf que pour Monsieur
Durand c'est hors de question de vendre
ce tableau ce faux utrilo parce que ça
ça va nuire à sa réputation de marchands
de marchands il veut pas avoir cette
casserole là mais Smith insiste et dit
qu'il est prêt à mettre jusqu'à 1
million de francs donc à peu près 30 000
euros aujourd'hui ça reste quand même
une belle somme pour info
le plan est le suivant monsieur Smith
propose une énorme somme d'argent à
Monsieur Hervé pour que Monsieur Hervé
qui est critique expert d'art aille
directement à la galerie de Monsieur
Durand achète une offre n'importe
laquelle la moins chère de manière
monsieur Smith va couvrir mes frais et
qu'ensuite il accède au bureau pour
faire le chèque et qu'une fois dans le
bureau il jette un coup d'oeil au
tableau discrètement de trilo pour voir
si c'est un vrai ou si c'est un faux et
que lui c'est monté un truc il se dit
voilà ça lui coûte un petit peu d'argent
de payer monsieur arrêt de lui donner
une enveloppe d'acheter une petite œuvre
de toute manière pour la revendre mais
au moins il en aura le cœur net Monsieur
Hervé va à la galerie il est accueilli
il a accueilli comme il se doit par
Monsieur Durand c'est un petit milieu
donc chacun se connaît à ce moment-là et
à cette époque dans le milieu de l'art
Monsieur Hervé flash sur une toile
propose à Monsieur durant lui acheter la
négocié un petit peu pour rendre
l'affaire on va dire un petit peu plus
vrai ils vont dans le bureau pour faire
l'achat pour faire le chèque et là
monsieur réservé dit à Monsieur Durand
qu'il a un coup de téléphone assez
important à passer qu'il a oublié de le
passer donc il demande s'il peut le
faire depuis le bureau donc monsieur
durant l'autorise bien sûr et par ceci
d'intimité le laisse seul dans le bureau
et c'est une fois qu'il est seul dans le
bureau que Monsieur Hervé va chercher la
toile elle est là où monsieur Smith lui
avait dit d'ailleurs posé à côté de la
corbeille en papier elle est à même le
sol c'est la place du Tertre comme lui
avait signifié monsieur Smith ça a l'air
d'être un vrai ultra lot et il observe
sous toutes ses coutures et son
expertise est formelle l'oeuvre d'art
est un vrai Utral mais cette toile est
une véritable pièce de musée c'est une
toile de la plus grande période du
peintre c'est une de celle qui vaut le
plus cher il y a limite monsieur harvest
demande pourquoi Monsieur Durand quand
même qui s'y connaît dans son affaire
n'a pas n'a pas détecté que c'était une
vraie toile parce que c'est sûr à 100%
pour lui alors il se dit que c'est
peut-être parce que il a acheté cette
toile comme quand il était étudiant
monsieur à raconter et que à cette
époque là il s'y connaissait moins et
puis puisque la personne lui avait vendu
ce qu'elle croyait être un faux ben lui
il a toujours considéré comme faux il
l'a pas remise en question Monsieur
Hervé court à l'hôtel de monsieur Smith
lui dit que c'est bon c'est vrai c'est
il est réel du coup monsieur Smith
retourne chez Monsieur Durand et il lui
dit voilà j'ai pensé à votre toile toute
la nuit ces derniers jours je veux
l'obtenir j'ai un coup de coeur dessus
je veux l'obtenir et là commence des
négociations sans fin parce que Monsieur
durant veut pas lâcher la toile il
rappelle en permanence la valeur
sentimentale mais en plus il insiste
très lourdement sur le fait qu'il ne
veut surtout pas voir la réputation de
faire circuler de fausses toile dans le
milieu et que pour ça c'est hors de
question et monsieur Smith de l'autre
côté essaye de faire des petits appels
des émotions il dit voilà je suis un bon
client on est devenu amis quand même au
fil des années donc vous pouvez bien me
faire ce plaisir là en plus je vous
demande pas de me la donner je vous
l'achète je suis prêt à mettre de
l'argent
contre moi donc qui prépare un papier et
monsieur Smith écrit je soussigné
monsieur Smith reconnu avoir acheté un
faux tableau à Monsieur durant en toute
connaissance de cause qui m'a
expressément notifié que le tableau ne
valait pas les deux millions de francs
que je lui ai proposé pour l'achat tout
m'a été clairement spécifié et c'est moi
qui ai souhaité acheter ce faux tableau
reconnu comme tel par Monsieur Durand
pour cette somme monsieur Smith sorry
parce que il trouve ça un peu un peu
délicat un peu élégant donc il se plie à
l'exigence il fait le petit papier il le
date il le signe il fait le chèque et il
part avec son tableau vous vous doutez
bien que c'est pas la fin de l'histoire
monsieur Smith retourne à l'hôtel et le
lendemain Monsieur Hervé le critique et
l'expert reçoit un coup de fil paniqué
de monsieur Smith il veut pas lui dire
ce qui se passe par téléphone il veut
que Monsieur Hervé Vienne le plus vite
possible à l'hôtel donc Monsieur Hervé
se précipite à l'hôtel et il trouve un
monsieur Smith blanc livide affolé
paniquer
au bout de sa vie la place du Tertre du
trilo est posée sur une chaise dans la
dans la chambre et monsieur avait ne
comprend pas et là il a réussi à avoir
le tableau qui voulait devrait être le
plus heureux des hommes et monsieur
Smith lui dit ce matin me réveillant
j'ai voulu regarder le tableau donc je
l'ai ouvert je l'ai posé sur la chaise
j'ai reculé pour admirer l'oeuvre du
maître
et j'ai une drôle d'impression une
sensation bizarre alors Monsieur Hervé
l'expert s'approche du tableau le regard
il recule il pousse un cri il fait mieux
mais ça c'est pas le bon c'est un faux
ça alors c'est un faux très réussi mais
ça reste un faux et bizarrement il faut
que quelques secondes pour se rendre
compte que c'est un faux Smith passe de
la peur à la colère il est furieux
contre l'expert et il accuse de l'avoir
berné lui a dit comment vous avez pu
m'affirmer que c'était un vrai alors que
vous m'avez fait acheter un faux pour 2
millions de francs monsieur Harvester
franc et comprend ce qui s'est passé le
tableau qui a vu monsieur Smith dans le
bureau était un vrai et le tableau qu'il
a vu lui-même était un vrai c'est sûr
c'est irréfutable ça veut dire que au
moment où ils ont fait l'achat monsieur
Durand a substitué le vrai tableau par
un faux tableau au moment de l'emballage
donc Monsieur Hervé dit vous devez aller
voir Monsieur Durand vous faire
rembourser et s'il veut pas vous
l'attaquez en justice pour réparation
Vous portez plainte contre lui
c'est là que monsieur Smith s'est senti
un petit peu pris au dépourvu et un
petit peu humilié par Monsieur Durand en
réalité il s'est jamais senti aussi
misérable de toute sa vie et il avoue à
Monsieur Hervé qu'il a signé un papier
comme quoi il reconnaît avoir acheté un
faux tableau
utrilo la place du Théâtre à Monsieur
Durand pour 2 millions de francs en
précisant que Monsieur durant l'a
expressément prévenu qu'il s'agissait
d'un faux tableau et qu'il ne valait pas
cette valeur et que monsieur Smith
lâcheté cette valeur à sa demande à lui
il peut rien faire vous l'avez compris
monsieur durant avec calculé son coût
depuis le départ moi je pense que il en
avait marre de ce client qui lui parlait
mal qui était irascible avec tout son
personnel avec tout le monde qui
essayait toujours d'étirer des prix vers
le bas etc je pense qu'il a il a monté
ce coup là pour lui donner une leçon
parce que il est milliardaire ça ne leur
apparent du moins riche même si ça aura
rendu monsieur durant un peu plus riche
mais que ça pas quand même transformer
sa vie et qui s'est dit bah voilà je lui
donnais une bonne leçon et puis je vais
prendre un petit peu de sous en même
temps des histoires d'escroquerie comme
ça dans les peintures il y en a beaucoup
mais celle de Monsieur Durand et
monsieur Smith c'est la seule que je
connaisse dans cette version si vous
aimez ça d'ailleurs il y a histoire de
faussaire qui est sorti en 2021 sur
Netflix avec l'histoire de paye qui a
faussaire qui a détourné quand même 80
millions c'est beaucoup avaient avec ses
faux tableaux après je me pose toujours
la question pourquoi on a cette
fascination là pour les escrocs pour les
faussaires
surtout comme ça quand il s'attaque au
plus riche il y a un petit côté un petit
peu Robin des Bois si si on regarde les
travaux de Sartre on peut se dire que en
fait il nous fascine parce que ils sont
libres ils sont libres
et ils sont pas en quête d'eux-mêmes en
fait mais il s'en fiche d'être
authentique et d'être bourré de défaut
et je pense que ça aussi il y a un côté
fascinant parce que je pense que ni vous
ni moi enfin vous je sais pas en fait
vous êtes trop nombreux au dosage mais
on peut être excité par l'idée de cette
ES non on ne le ferait pas nous-mêmes je
pense pas qu'on arriverait à assumer moi
j'arriverai pas en tout cas l'assumer
donc je pense qu'il y a cette
fascination aussi de oh là là il a osé
le faire qui qui nous donne ce truc là
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il y a de plus en
plus de séries sur les escrocs parce
qu'on les regarde presque envie de cette
liberté là je prenais ça très direct
quand ce sont des gens qui refusent la
quête de l'être et et comme nous on est
en plein dans cette quête là il y a un
côté de waouh ils l'ont fait mais en
vrai c'est parce qu'on va être on va pas
être des escrocs on va pas être me
monsieur Durand on veut pas être
monsieur Smith non plus on peut juste
que les choses elles se passent bien
normalement pour tout le monde mais en
tout cas j'espère que cette histoire là
elle vous a plu des histoires
d'escroquerie dans les formes à la belle
marque je vous en a raconté pas mal si
vous avez pas tous vu je vous mets un
lien dans la description et si vraiment
vous aimez beaucoup n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur Instagram parce que peut-être
je vais en faire en plus sous forme de
podcast donc je vous préviendrai de ça
là-bas quant à nous on se voit j'espère
en avril mais au juin sur l'une des
dates de tournée qui reste me demandez
pas pour les autres villes elles sont
passées déjà depuis le mois de septembre
entre septembre et avril et une chose
est sûre c'est qu'on pourra se retrouver
au mois de novembre à la salle Pleyel
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao